let's face it
the architecture industry has a lot of
issues
i've only been in the industry for a
couple of years but from day one i've
heard the same complaints over and over
again i mean if you just think about the
idea of being an architect it sounds
like it could be the coolest job ever
and it's a very noble profession
so why is it that
architects
and the architecture profession
seem to be constantly having these
problems when other industries actually
seem to be adapting and thriving into
the future
so as you guys know i do try to be
pretty transparent about the pros and
cons of being an architect
but i really wanted to get the
perspective of someone who had a broader
experience
so
i turned to evelyn lee who is the
founder of practice of architecture
where they help architecture firms
expand their opportunities beyond the
traditional business model of an
architecture firm
by looking at lessons from other
industries she's a licensed architect
working in tech she's actually a senior
experience designer at slack
and she's also been pretty heavily
involved in the aia for more than a
decade in elected leadership
and as someone who straddles both
architecture and tech industries i felt
like she could bring a really unique
perspective to the discussion first of
all i wanted to understand from her
point of view where the issues and
challenges were facing architecture
compared to other industries
i think it is it is culture i think it
is how we train and develop our people i
would argue that we tend to lead by fear
rather than
by allowing people a safe place to fail
which means that they feel that they can
speak up more i would say that we tend
to be less transparent when it would
help us to be more transparent about
everything down to the financials
of every single project that anyone is
working on to understand
when how many hours that they have on
the project how many hours we've
consumed
and
how they should manage their
i think everyone's an adult but how they
could better manage their time towards
seeing that project through there's some
large
larger firms where like literally the
project managers will not share
libraries with one another
so if we had a better culture just
around share like knowledge sharing yes
we are competing with other architecture
firms but i think we're competing with
so much more out in the world if we play
our cars right and if we raise the value
of the architects then there's plenty of
work out there for all of us
so we should be helping each other out
more than we should be
worrying about who we're competing with
but how do we actually raise the value
of architects i mean from my experience
the general public already has a very
little understanding of what we actually
do and i mean we're already so
overworked
with tasks beyond just the design of the
building at least from my work at
mk think we
the strategy group in particular was
created because we felt that architects
were brought in too late
into
the the conversation and we didn't stay
around long enough what can we do from a
real estate and planning perspective to
help clients decide whether or not they
even need a building
we always talk about kind of adaptive
reuse
being key to sustainability right now
and we have such older buildings stock
and it's good to do that but like okay
so what type of services do we need to
provide to make sure that we're in front
of the client when we're they're
deciding
where like where their business needs to
be located how big their footprint needs
to be and what what type of building
they need to be in to be successful i
think there's there's a lot more on the
front end that frankly
i would our architects are going to
listen to this and say we already do
that we do that for free though
so often so those are services that we
should be
charging for i also have a lot of
friends
and younger
younger firms that have gone
into supporting like branding and design
development for businesses at a really
young stage and then when those
businesses need are ready to have brick
and mortar space
those architecture firms are the first
that they turn to
and then on on the back end i think
there's especially with all of the
information that is contained with our
in our bim models and all of the
modeling we do around how energy
efficient
our buildings are supposed to be i think
there's a little big opportunity to look
at can we move to
at least outside the realm of
like residential
operators of space and can we help our
help the new owners better operate their
spaces going forward so they function
as efficiently as we intended them to
that's i mean that's just two two very
high level ways that we could look at um
expanding our services beyond the life
of the
not beyond the life of the building
we're actually expanding our services to
include the entire life of the building
rather than
just the part where we're improving the
building right
yeah yeah a lot of times i feel like we
have a lot of that information yeah like
in-house
but we just have to spend the time to
filter it and make it usable for people
and make people understand it in order
for us to do that
we need to have
flexibility and like fees and
time
so yeah it's kind of a chicken or the
egg so
i think the theme here is thinking
beyond just construction
and i think it makes a lot of sense like
whether you're designing a library or a
restaurant the design of the building
itself is actually kind of a small part
of the process and frankly
like stakeholders and business owners
they really care about the operations of
the space rather than the look or the
design of the space but at the same time
when you're running a project and you're
working at the firm
we rarely have time to build new skill
sets let alone
build an entirely new area of expertise
so how can architecture firms
realistically build this new area of
expertise so if you're in architecture
practice and you're looking to
understand where are there additional
opportunities for us to expand value i
think it really starts by
understanding all of the talent that you
have within your current staff
and what they're available to do i think
it also starts with having deeper
conversations with with the clients
about kind of
building that relationship about about
their their business beyond
architecture the the crossover to tech
has provided me a whole new like
experience of how
the various different ways for instance
that we can actually treat employees um
humanely
um in ways that i just didn't experience
even at did you say humanely
i said humanely
but no i mean just like like treat
employees like people in a way that i
just never experienced
at architecture firms there's so much
talk of
the culture that is lost that has been
lost during this hybrid time but really
if you provide a great onboarding
experience there's there's the ability
to still onboard people to the culture
of your firm but
pre-pandemic um
you know i i would i would argue that
every firm that i work for every
architecture firm that i work for there
wasn't an onboarding process there was a
there was two days where i sat around
side like signing
all the legal documents that every new
employee signs but um
but that doesn't tell me anything about
the culture of the firm and that um that
doesn't make me kind of excited about my
decision
to work there
like from the first day that i walk in
so
so even even the smallest lessons i
think there's a lot to be learned
from outside of our
our little
viewpoint on on how to run a business i
don't think we look outside enough
frankly i remember in our last interview
you were telling me about your
onboarding experience at slack and one
of the first things they said was
even if you're a new hire your life
experiences means that you can be a
contributor from day one and i thought
that was like
a really
motivating thing for like
young people who just like started a
firm that's the line that we draw it
doesn't matter if you're an intern it
doesn't matter if you're coming in as a
senior vice president like you made it
through our hiring like process
if it was a rigorous and robust enough
hiring process then we believe that you
have valuable contributions to make to
this organization
and you should question you should have
the ability to question everything that
we're doing and if we don't have an
answer we should be questioning if we're
doing it the right way we're not going
to invite you to the client meeting
until x y and z you aren't going to come
out onto the construction site until you
pass all these things i think other
industries kind of
and and this is not true of all firms i
realize i'm making general
generalizations but i feel like the
transparency of the communication kind
of throwing people into the middle of
things happens
on a more frequent basis
outside of architecture i think the
businesses that are going to thrive in
the future are the ones that are gonna
leverage their human connections and
build not just spaces for people but
build business models that focuses on
people but so there's this really small
practice i would say of like five people
or less in la
um just this season called stainer
architects
and they have this love of food and the
the guy there like started up this
relationship with this friend who has
deep expertise in culinary work so
they're this architecture firm that also
does a lot with food systems and they
actually help
restaurants
with menu planning and their entire food
systems and then they've designed and
developed and deliver and own a few of
their own they own a wine bar they own a
restaurant they own a few of their own
hospitality spaces so that's just kind
of like
i mean talk about a small firm who's
just
i don't even know how many different
business entities the owner has created
because i think he has a design he has
his typical residential
practice but he also has
like a business under various different
hospitality entities he has a design
build business
he's super entrepreneurial i think in
every sense of the word and he's doing a
lot for such a small group of people um
but as an example of like
all the things that you can you can
dabble in a lot of things and still find
success in it um and he's just gone
really deep into hospitality and in
specific food systems
so that was also that's been really
interesting i just want to say
although architecture has a lot of
problems
there's also so many positives it is a
great profession and it's a really fun
job
and one of the great things is that
there's some really incredible
passionate communities if you're
interested in joining my little
community and hearing more from me i
have a newsletter a discord community
with a series of membership tiers that
you can join to access different perks
one of the perks is access to these full
in-depth interviews um as well as live q
a sessions with myself
and i'll leave links to all of this down
in the description before we end i want
to share a quick message from our
sponsor one of the things i think is
going to transform the architecture
industry is an improvement in the
processes i just came out of a month of
writing specs so the inefficiency of
this process is still really fresh in my
mind and i think a big part of that
comes from the fact that we deal with
such a massive amount of information
but that information isn't consolidated
into a central resource and turned into
useful information a lot of the times we
resort to using products that we've
already used in the office
or we rely heavily on our product reps
who can be really wonderful
but
their end goal is to get you to use
their products they're not your friends
acelab was founded by a team of
architects who wanted to modernize how
we research and specify products with an
accessible data-driven platform that's
unbiased transparent and 100 free yes
free you can search for products based
on type performance budget and even
aesthetic you can compare the data so
you can get a real apples to apples
comparison you can download product data
sheets spec sheets and cad or bim files
and they also have case studies and
educational resources that can help you
become a better architect and a designer
all of this like i said is a hundred
percent free so you can follow the link
in my description and check out the
platform and just see how it can improve
your design process and with that i'll
see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you